jool is a very good sport I thought it
would be interesting to hear your take
on this song that I wrote in sixth grade
let me play a little of it for the
audience in case they're not familiar
this is a silver nickels golden dome
case they're not familiar well you know
there might be one it might be one fan
new fan out there most people are
familiar with this work go ahead Mary
yes
[Applause]
did you understand what I'm talking
about here my sixth-grade mentality like
people who take money you don't want to
let jewel tell us what it said to her I
said nothing to her she was doing it as
a favor to me did it say anything to you
actually the song I was surprised
actually what do you mean that's really
gonna suck
how did somebody asked me to do this
usually seems like we put a song I wrote
you're like oh my god Lord I like that
you're missing the best part
I like the drum part well go ahead yeah
like probably you're not seeing no
you're right thanks very good Jerry dick
away
[Music]
classics turn
yeah are you prepared to do this so now
I am kind of prepared I've you can
probably hear I've had a cold and I'm
had laryngitis so today's the first day
of spoken in a week no excuses
yeah well I've been singing this in my
head I haven't really been able to sing
it on that piece of paper
here's Jewell doing a song I wrote oh I
forgot the beginning do you want to do
the beginning Mary come play with me
I'll give you a silver nickel
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I will give you seven golden are you
here
The Devil's jump
silver
[Music]
marry I gotta say
[Music]
we'll be
[Music]
next
[Music]
I knew there was a reason I wrote that
song I mean you've got to admit music is
good